remember this 20-mile backup from
thanksgiving weekend traffic around the
nevada california border is horrible
especially when it comes to weekend
travel now leaders from both states are
trying to do something about it bianca
holman breaks down the changes coming to
the border
it's no secret those traveling back to
california from las vegas face major
traffic issues on i-15 southbound but
now short-term relief is on the way he
just called
and asked
and said can you focus on this
and then he followed up he said they
fought up within a couple days that call
governor sister lag made to california
governor gavin newsom has prompted
action
for five miles south of the state line
the shoulder will turn into an
additional travel lane this is a 12
million dollar investment for california
from existing funds
work will begin in spring 2022 and wrap
by summer 2022. it feels great and i
can't thank governor newsom enough in
california for what they've done
governor newsom says there are talks
with brightline for a long-term solution
for high-speed rail and discussions with
agencies in local jurisdictions about
more road expansion in years to come
however this immediate expansion is
expected to help ease freight troubles
it should help get you know the semis
moving from the long beach and from l.a
up to las vegas so hopefully it will
help all the way around with just the
general traffic flow and supply chain is
a big part of that as this helps
truckers tourism will benefit as well
many have experienced or heard about the
8 to 12 hour delays back to california
hopefully when you're looking at the
labor day traffic or maybe the fourth of
july traffic this will already be in
place so it's going to go a long long
way towards one cutting down on the time
the travel and two making it safer
bianca holman live local now
many local leaders have advocated for
this for months this is a tweet from
mayor carolyn goodman she says quote
glad to see gavin newsom and governor
cecilak finally address the i-15
bottleneck